what's up everybody this the biggest
boss in the game ricky rose aka ravioli
and this right here is my style history
me growing up in miami style to me was
fila that was style
troop
that was styled mcm that was style all
my style influences came from your own
tv wraps gold chains
silk sweatsuits
balis if he was winning from miami
martha was gonna let you know that he
was winning
that's something that
groovy lou
my stylist groovy lou got to take
responsibility for
roseanne no none about that [ __ ] when
you came to new york
force fed you air hardy them jeans and
them chains hanging off your pocket
man that [ __ ] looked horrendous and back
then
groovy wanted me to wear ed hardy so bad
he would go buy the real hardy shirt cut
the logo off and put it on a
big and tall dxl4x
so we kind of was halfway capping
forgive me those probably with some
goddamn um red monkeys
i don't even know what kind of shoes are
those
maybe nike boots as you can see i was
wearing prada shades
i'ma blame groovy loo for them ugly
prada shades you know at that point as
an artist i was buying jewels
and trading them [ __ ] back in to get
that money back and get some more would
you wear this outfit again yes or no i'm
not gonna say i wouldn't of course not
the shirt i'm sure my uncle's in
mississippi somewhere still rocking that
[ __ ] i'm praying for anybody
wearing ed hardy right now
may the lord forgive them lying
i love big pendants and i wish i still
had those because to me
you know the way my brand continues to
grow i believe those are
10 times more valuable than i actually
paid for just imagine if somebody
sitting at home could purchase that rick
ross chain right now with that mtv sweat
that drip down on the diamonds
you know the beauty i see when i look at
this jacket is
my
aspirations i see my desires
i was a 350 pound [ __ ] just had
the desire to be an offending jacket was
this a real fendi jacket of course not
of course not
that was a groovy little whip game
remix i would have to pass on the jacket
right now you know what i mean yeah i
don't lost a little weight so i wear the
real fendi now you know i mean it's
something about that real fabric and i'm
not taking anything away from groovy loo
i just wanted findy and guess what he
delivered it
that vinyl that they used and that spray
paint that was used
to put the f's
groovy lou got a wedding
the same way i had the word now he got
away yeah look at that spray paint you
got to put the ed hardy t-shirt on with
the jacket
not at once please
not at once i'm talking about if you
want some halloween [ __ ] that's cool
that looked like i was just on some cool
vibe that night is that kuji yeah oh
that's fly
yeah i could wear that again i love kuji
i don't wear a lot of it but most
definitely once it's the cool time of
the year i always love to rock coochie
pieces of those kuji sweaters that came
out back then were priceless i still
have some of the same ones even though i
can't fit them i just i'ma hold on to
those i know if i auctioned off that
past shoes right now those js with that
rick ross dna it's no telling what
they could possibly go for i want to say
that's a breitling that came out with
the big bezels when they came out they
had to like i say b06 maybe that was a
cool thing i love that watch see that
bracelet hold on that bracelet zoom man
come on now
yeah
that's some flash [ __ ] i believe i got
that
like in
07 from johnny dang type [ __ ]
out there in texas you know what i'm
saying you go through texas those boys
had them big bracelets and all that i
had to get me some of that
that's most definitely miami you know
what i'm saying that sun bright doing
some cool [ __ ]
you're on the beach you make a few moves
why not
live your life that's what that color
represent denim ones nice silk
he's gonna jump [ __ ]
you know at that point i started getting
stuff taylor made that may have been for
my homie i don't know groovy lumia did
that for me as well yeah shout out to
groovy lou baby that [ __ ] was fly that i
overlooked that
oh you couldn't tell me nothing right
there
i know you're wanting rose right there
them jeans was sliding off my ass too
it might have been them dolce high tops
with the gold tips the musashi's in
themselves was real then
i ain't have ruby making me the 300 zip
up joints no more that's just some fly
player [ __ ]
yeah
roll that sleeve up so that watch
breathe that's a presidential rolex i
ain't mad at that you know but when you
grow up a big boy you don't mind having
on that 25 brown leather joint like that
you're a fat [ __ ] sit down
somewhere boy tell us a little bit about
formal wear do you like uh suiting up
and dressing up for the occasion yeah
love suits
most definitely
love to get a little dressed up get
classy
i love to hit the red carpet in the
black i love to hit it with the black
and i love to make sure my jewels do a
lot of the talking and i really want to
be comfortable at by this point of me
going to the grammys all of my my
loafers are soft loafers and everything
is custom-made so i didn't go into any
boutiques
and buy none of these looks they're all
tailor-made it's most definitely a style
statement when you can just drape
something over your shoulder and walk
the entire carpet and be comfortable
because it was made just for your
shoulders you dig
let's talk about sweats a little too a
lot of times when you're performing you
wear the jumpsuits right
so why is it a comfort thing it's
most definitely a comfort thing
i hit the stage i move around a little
more
comfortable if i get sweaty i could take
the jacket off throw the jacket in the
crowd whatever it is
whatever it is it's most definitely a
comfort thing a lot of times
i get dressed around the jewels
the jewels are number one
why not let's put on 20 chains you know
what i mean it just take me back to you
know just my early days sneakers was
always to me
growing up the most important
part of getting dressed [ __ ] your jeans
[ __ ] your shirt i don't care you know
what i'm saying in miami we wore white
t-shirts i love my new dior i love the
dojs i actually wore them yesterday but
when i think of my favorite jays i go
back to ben and youngster those map
lottos
those ll cool j troops
you know what i'm saying them shits
touch me
you know them [ __ ] cost so much i i
knew not even asked for them i didn't
ask for them but i just looked at the
[ __ ] and was like
one day to come where do you like to get
your silk shirts from do you go into
like the gucci store versace store and
everything most definitely i believe
that's a versace so that was just a silk
button up some white jeans and loafers
out the wrong i wanted some rose chains
i could stack
and it just so happened i pulled them
out
i had those cartier shades on them big
stud vvs diamonds on them i wore versace
button up those may have been vents
shorts
those are for real custom chanel
sneakers miami that looks like prime
fish or prime 112 prime s prime 112
jumped out prime 112 the rolls royce
ghost
that was the event i was invited to by
the miami heat
dwyane wade
pat riley
jimmy butler
was a bunch of homies
that was a taylormade joint i'm sure
groovy lou made that those were some
fendi
sneakers
silk shirt
white jeans silk shirt semi-trench
looked like a gold bottle with luke
bella
my favorite champagne gold
medallion with a penny in the center
i actually bought that from an antique
store
what inspired this look right here
i believe what inspired that look is i
had just released a record
called green gucci suit featuring future
and what it was was really me just going
back
thinking of dappa dan
and the inspiration that i got from all
of the gear that he put together all my
favorite album covers when i saw rakim
eric being rakim you know and that's
what i thought about that night in the
studio so i did a record called green
gucci suit
and so i believe dapper dan may you know
put that together if not it was just
some cool [ __ ] it was real retro it was
a real throwback to the you know the
real hustler days it felt like some late
80s [ __ ] to me
colleen roy was actually putting
together
my birthday party
and of course this was a masquerade that
wanted to do something i've never done i
told her i've never even been to a party
really where you wore a mask and this
and that so of course she contacted
someone to put my mask together
the crown together just the whole vibe
and everybody came out
in that picture that's yg that's jeezy
myself and that's usher the yeah the red
jewels i just wanted to go with the
crown and it was just a whole vibe of
that jacket superfly shout out to groovy
little groovy lou custer makes jackets
custom does really he could does
everything he could do anything
you know he a legend new york city
did some [ __ ] with b.i.g back they need
to make history fashion-wise with a lot
of people but we really connected on
some cool [ __ ] yeah it's deeper than
just the fashion that's that's family
uh you already know what it is that was
us celebrating the history of d wade
you know the miami heat just the whole
family the whole city came out
it felt good
you know i had on my my heat jersey my
heat hat i had a maybach music custom
you know thin jacket to throw on
um i gave i gifted one to d weight as
well so i came out everybody showed love
stood up went crazy
and we just most definitely you know rep
d way my style and what i love still
remained the same i'm just in another
bracket now so i got access to a lot of
things now the the clothing designers
givenchy all the niemann markets they
open the doors and
other than that the things i i love
i don't believe that'll ever change you
know i still love the jewels a lot of
fashion you know what i mean shout out
to groovy lou
everybody who helped build my [ __ ] you
know what i mean it made it happen oh
groovy lou here
yeah
yeah y'all that's groovy lou this the
[ __ ] this is the [ __ ] god designed
majority shot i didn't even know he came
up here that's what that's what he
brought me i didn't even know much
i ain't even know my dog was in here
y'all got the design other [ __ ] y'all
get to hear some of his words when he
was putting that silk [ __ ] together for
rosie said everything i said enough
didn't i keep it real yeah he threw me
under the bus got me back got to clean
me off you feel me you feel me you feel
me i appreciate it with that air hardy
you had to wear that air honey your
groove